um we will talk about the classical sony
time algorithm for finding round stage
of one b
it's a variant it's a part okay um
i
guess guess for some people this doesn't
make any difference whether i write that
or not right but uh i guess to me it
makes a difference so um this is don't
work with uh zeph landau
omega from here
and everyone can hear me fine right okay
let me just
very quickly set things up so we're
going to be talking about a
1d uh chain of qubits
cubic so each q bit or q deck is going
to be a d dimensional
system
and i have
n of them
so i'll label them from 1 to n one two
three
in general one in the middle i made
called i and then up to n
so that's our space um
and on that space we're given a local
nearest neighbor
hamiltonian
h
so it's the sum of local terms h1
up to h n minus one right so h1 acts on
the first two spins h2 acts on the these
two spins uh like this this is specified
to us there's normalization conditions
with the simplicity i'll assume that
each of these terms is positive and also
has norm
at most one
and now this hamiltonian has a ground
state right so
for the ground state
i'll write it as gamma and it has energy
that i'll call e0 so it's the minimum
energy
gamma h
and we're also given a precision
parameter
and the goal
um
the goal is to find a representation
efficient representation for something
that's kind of close to gamma so find uh
you know in this talk so i guess i don't
need to introduce a matrix product
states for anyone so find a matrix
product state representation
for a vector gamma tilde
such that
these are close so gamma theta gamma is
at least one minus delta so delta is
just my approximation think of it as a
small box approximation parameter a
small constant actually could be even
inverse polynomial in the length of the
chain
okay the question is whether we can
solve uh this problem right
so that's that's the problem um so so
the first question maybe should be um i
should say question is
uh does this uh representation exist so
does there exist a efficient polynomial
size representation for the ground state
so does a
small let's polynomial size
so when i say polynomial it'll always be
polynomial in the length of the chain
right the number of qubits that's the
parameter that grows the local dimension
d is is fixed like think of it as being
you know five or ten or something like
that right so there's a polynomial size
representation for the ground say a good
approximation to the ground state exist
um and so the answer
oh
yes no
no
so far this uh problem is qma hard
so if you believe that qma is bigger
than np there's no
point in the size representation
uh problem is qma hard it's q a hard
even in this setting right so i have a
one-dimensional hamiltonian it's local
nearest neighbors
if my dimension is at least eight right
so this is what sean so this is a uh
result by sean hargreen daniel
right so not yet so that's why exactly
so if i at that level of generality the
problem remains hard right it's a hard
problem it's just too too general right
i haven't put any structure on my
hamiltonian except the 1d local
structure so what i just wanted to say
is that
if we state it in this way we're not
going anywhere right this is just
to do anything impossible existence
yeah if you believe that cream is
different from np
uh then you know it's it's saying that
the problem is it's not in np so there's
no
witness that you could efficiently
verify no classical weakness
this is what i meant
but but
for the new existence so the
non-existence is just a mathematical
theorem say here is a hamiltonian that
does not exist exactly
but that's if you look for it depends
then you have to i don't want to get
into this i mean then you have to say
what you mean by a representation
yes oh one for them yes
yes okay so sure yeah so the answer is
okay right so the answer is no under no
assumptions yeah okay thanks um
all right so we need a little more
structure so the the the natural
structure to impose is that i'm going to
impose is that this hamiltonian has a
gap so there's a unique ground state
in the ground state and then there's an
energy gap above this ground state so
there's a gap
so i'm going to have the first excited
energy e1 and e1 is at least e0 plus
some gap delta
and delta is a
constant gap that's infinite on the
system says so so if if we have a uh
a critical system you know an ordinary
system critical system with a log
uh from the entanglement entropy that
would still be polynomial
with the usual algorithm
what would we put in real uh the
computation time for a dmig
well as far as there are no dmrg there's
no bonds in the computation there's no
there's no
rigorous bound right but you mean
you know the entanglement grows the mps
grows you know
you know
m grows in a polynomial
fashion and so it's still polynomial yep
the the the size of that so i'm just
wondering if
you know you prove this for the gap case
but could you also do that for a long
verb
delta s in the order one over and yeah
what will it be very well i'll say it in
a moment so the dependence on right if
you allow delta to even moderately
go to zero with the system size at least
what we have is not going to perform
well at all but i'll say precisely it's
exponentially in the cap right
it's very fun
i'll say it in just just a minute
or we could skip to it i mean okay does
a representation exist the answer is yes
right so that's uh uh his things result
if you have a gap i mean in in in our
setting what that result is saying is
that there exists um
exists
the mps
for this gamma tinder here
of size or you could just say of a bond
dimension of size polynomial
in the length of the chain and the
approximation
so
um
this matrix product state exists and the
question is can you find it so it is
question two i guess question one
question two can you find it
and i guess if you give the answer the
answer is yes you know the mrg finds it
that's what dmrg does right so
yes dmrg finds you
except maybe it's not so clear right so
um in practice it finds it
in theory you can come up with examples
in which the energy gets stuck with
contrived examples in which gmrg gets
stuck in local minimum
there's in particular there's a nice
result where people hear or some of them
are here frank norbert ignacio um
showing that in some cases you can
construct have a artificial construction
of a local 1d hamiltonian like this such
that
there does exist a point on the size
matrix product state representation for
the ground state but if you could find
it
then you could also efficiently factor
numbers so which we don't know how to do
uh so presumably there so there are
cases in which this exists but it's
presumably hard to find it so these
constructions are artificial and in
particular they're not gout right these
systems so what this is saying is just
that
the fact that there is a representation
doesn't imply that i can find it i'm
going to have to use
you know this is background for
everybody i think everyone is so
familiar with uh sorry
did you just mean to say no the energy
may not have enough time
uh yeah yeah yeah this was well it
depends who you ask right so if you are
steve i don't know uh if you ask me
if you ask me
okay okay
no i i know there are hard things in the
context of this talk then the answer
well can you find it
dmrg
yes so that's i guess that's the point
of this talk is to give an algorithm
that always finds it under in this
context in these assumptions right
endpoint so this is what i was going say
what's the
result that i want to present so um so
it's right there so then we know the
difference here
so here
um there is a point over time algorithm
so there is an algorithm
that finds
the matrix product state representation
for this approximation gamma candle in
time
polynomial
in n
and
one over delta so it runs in polynomial
time provided uh the gap and the local
dimension are fixed so then the question
that
jens was asking is what's the dependence
on the gap okay this is pretty bad so i
have to say what is the exponent here
it's a constant exponent as long as all
the parameters are constant but this
exponent is
two
to the then there's a
poly logarithmic dependence
on the local dimension
and the gap shows up here right so this
is a column here
so if you want a certain precision this
is pretty good it's going to be
polynomial in the precision that you
want
um but
uh the gap shows up in the exponent of
the exponent of n so it's not the
exponential in the gap what this means
is that you know if delta even goes to
zero as uh one over logger make a lift
fast you have an exponential time
algorithm so it doesn't do well at all
not good
but it's exponentially
better than
the bolts
the dependence on small d right so this
the dependence of small d just relies on
the how good the reals are and so this
dependence is a dependent that comes out
from the paper by uh
formation that
and it is exponentially better than
so that they all has an arrow in total
energy or in energy per site sorry it's
still a time it's an arrow in the total
energy
it's actually air well so
um
in that case you could get both because
you can really think of delta as being
um you know one over n squared or
something so delta is much smaller than
the length of the chain so it's uh let's
say total i mean we can get
i mean the way i phrased it is just how
close you are to the actual ground state
well actually so if i write this then
it's going to be energy precise and the
total error in energy could be n times
delta
will be of n times delta and but i can
choose delta to be one over n cubed if i
want it's the same
other questions
i can very deep but it's going to scale
very coolly with d so i'm thinking of d
as being fixed
please please that's how i think of this
deal
but if you vary it
if you want something that's efficient
you should think of d as being fixed and
pretty smart
maybe more common
if our translation environment system
looks like a nut bank this steroid is a
very strict one
because for the large system overlap
wave function can be rather small even
though the locally wave functions very
very close
so here you'll require the whole wave
function for overlapping here one so
that's very very strict yeah so right so
if you so i'm not assuming it's
translation environment so if you had a
translation invariant system for which
you are really thinking of the chain as
being infinite or semi-indian
um then you you'd have to phrase your
goal differently um i agree you'd have
to say i want to approximate the energy
you know
you know even in a quicker quicker
algorithm yeah we didn't quite study
that question i think it's an
interesting question we were talking
about it the other day we're not
so the goal for the talk is is is to get
a little bit into into that like give
you the ideas that go into the the
algorithm how it works um
not so much because i expect many of you
to you know go home and want to
implement the algorithm
but because i think that there's a
couple uh nice ideas that go into the
into making this work these are ideas
that use the structure of the problem in
a certain way right so i have a
structure which is it's one-dimensional
local hamiltonian and then there's this
gap so there's a couple tools that we
introduced that make use of this
structure of the hamiltonian in order to
devise the algorithm and i think these
tools could be useful um in other
contexts right so
the main goal is not necessarily you
have a algorithm that you can implement
it's to go further than that study
apply these tools to other problems that
some of you may be interested in like
maybe time evolution or maybe
um deep states at some temperatures or
maybe two-dimensional you know some of
the tools crucially use the
one-dimensional structure of course and
some of them don't so maybe they're
interesting to study the two
two dimensions
okay so i want to give you a picture of
what the algorithm does to start with
and then i'll say a little bit more uh
details
so it's going to be at a very high level
it's a little bit like dmrg it's going
to be a iterative algorithm
so what we're looking for is this um
approximation for the ground state this
matrix product state
representation which is something that
looks like this right that lives it
lives on the whole
chain
and we're trying to find this object and
we're going to construct it iteratively
proceeding from left to right so i'm
going to first construct tensors that
live on the first qubit then on the
first two qubits the first three qubits
etc until i arrive at the end of the
chain
dmrg does this a little bit but it does
a local optimization of each tensor
keeping one matrix product state and it
sort of goes back and forth we're only
going to do one pass so just go from the
left to the right
but one difference is that i'm not going
to maintain
just
one candidate solution that can be
extended to ground state i'm going to
maintain a huge bunch
of candidate solutions so i'll maintain
a lot of partial matrix product states
on the sites up to i among which i know
i can find
something that you know when i go all
the way to the end will give me my good
approximation but i maintain this whole
set of vectors and i sort of drag it
along
so to explain how this is done um
zeph has a nice metaphor that sort of
thinks of this algorithm as uh
walking on a icy lake and trying not to
fall through the ice
but then i thought you know given the
weather i mean this is not a this
strategy is not going to work um so i
have another metaphor to give you for
what the algorithm uh
how the algorithm works is a classic
metaphor of the needle in the haystack
right so this is the problem that we're
trying to to solve we're trying to find
a needle uh in a historic uh the needle
is the
ground state
and the haystack
is the space of all possibilities right
those possible matrix product states
and we're going to have this needle in
this haystack
and think of this haystack as something
that we're going to drag around from the
first qubit all the way till the end of
the chain
so when i start my day it's easy to set
up a haystack that contains the needle
what's the needle the needle is
some matrix product state here
that can be extended to a good
approximation to the ground state and
we'll construct a haystack that's
guaranteed to contain that needle well
that's easy because this is very small
space right this is d dimensional i have
my real law so i have a bound on the
size of this so i can just take sort of
a epsilon knight or all possible
candidates i take all possible pieces of
hay that live on that space and it's
guaranteed to contain my needle the
needle is whatever will eventually lead
to the ground state so i can get started
i have to hashtag the needle
and i'm going to proceed from left to
right
including more and more qubits
and growing the size of this haystack to
make sure that they always contain the
needle i always contain the left half of
something that can be extended to this
gamma tilde
yeah what do you mean
on the first so you are tracing out the
rest no i'm considering objects that are
that look like this so tensors that have
one physical index
when i start and one logical index here
that has a certain dimension b which is
as large let's say as it needs to be you
know given the arria law
so that's what i have my haystack when i
start the day contains objects that look
like this
and then the first the second day
is going to contain objects that look
like this and the third day objects like
look like this
of course the sort of obvious problem is
that this is you drag haystacks you know
on the ground and they pick up more hay
and yeah yeah so how does your size they
hate that grow with uh yeah so i mean
you know this is the metaphor uh
but obviously it grows right obviously
it grows and and this is the main
problem we're facing even if it grew
just moderately right by a factor two at
every step
i continue this by the time i end here i
have a haystack that contains a needle
the haystack is exponentially large
okay i haven't achieved anything right i
mean of course i have an exponentially
large space so this is where you need
ideas right so uh and that's where
uh there's a couple interesting ideas
that we're going to introduce so there's
two procedures that we introduced that
keep the size
of this haystack under control so that
when we arrive at the end of the chain
we've i mean we still have a polynomial
size haystack that contains the needle
and then we can find it because when we
arrive at the end we have a way to
characterize the needle right it's just
a state that let's say minimizes the
energy so this is how we find it in the
histogram provided a stack is not too
big so how do you keep things under
control so there's two procedures um
one is is pretty simple you have a
haystack it's too big you want to make
it smaller what do you do
you put it on fire right so
the first idea we have is that
um i mean i'll show you in more detail
what this means but the idea is that
if you arrive
at a certain step and your haystack has
grown too much you want to reduce it you
light it up later on fire and this um
will reduce the size of the haystack and
because the ground state is a needle you
know it's in metal it's it's going to
stay
so that's that's
pretty straightforward so this step is
going to use but i'll just say this is
going to use the one-dimensional
structure
in a key way right also the gap but the
one dimension
okay we have another problem which is
that if i do this um all the time so i
proceed through the chain
and i keep lighting it on fire uh to
reduce the size what's gonna happen i
mean this needle is getting hot right
and if i do it too often the needle gets
hot and hot and hot and the hot needle
will happen to it it gets bent
so the quality of my approximation
the needle the approximation gamma tilde
or partial approximation come until i'm
dragging around is going to decrease
very fast as i keep that's the cost of
keeping the his
size under control
so i need another procedure to maintain
the quality of the approximation
and so that's the procedure that i need
to combat um you know the effects of the
fire of the heat so whether we're going
to use um
ice or a fridge or something like this
so let's say ice let's say fridge
let's say let's say fridge
so this kind of a cooling down procedure
that's supposed to combat the effects of
the fire and this is how the procedure
is is going to go you're going to make a
few steps this haystack set of candidate
solutions is going to grow up by too
much
you want to put it on fire
this has the risk of messing up the
quality of the approximation too much so
first you cool it down so first it's
going to have to be a procedure that
increases the quality of your
approximations makes them better if
they're dealt out they become better
than dental this is what i call sort of
cooling down solidifying um
and then we're going to heat it up get
rid of the extra hay and then continue
until the end we have a point of insight
says
so that's the idea um
is it clear
yeah
okay
so okay so so now let me give you a
little bit more details right now
i want to be a bit more substantial um
but this was just maybe something that
you can hang on to as i gave you the
more details maybe it was helpful maybe
not maybe it was entertaining maybe not
who knows so so because we're serious
now uh you know we're going to stop this
fuss with ridiculous language and use uh
some much more fancy uh terms for
everything so the needle uh this i told
you right this would be the ground state
or actually it's what i'll call
i'll often refer to left half
mps
right so where the left half mps is
really the kind of object i was uh
drawing here it's a matrix product state
that lives on the first eye sites and it
has an open bond on the last
on the last side
so the haystack we have a very fancy
name for this one it's going to be
called the viable set and i'll explain
what the bible says
is
fire is something that we call
decoupling so this is going to use the
one-dimensional structure the coupling
procedure and the fridge is a
interesting object uh that's called
approximate ground state projection this
is going to be some kind of an operator
that you can apply to your vectors in
order to improve the quality of
approximation that you have so far
so i explain all of these um
so first i'll i'll give the the main
definition which is this haystack so
viable set
definition so what's a his what's a
viable set so
it has four parameters but that's about
as much parameters as there'll be in the
talk so it's it's we're going through
them so there's a
qubit index
there's a quality parameter delta
and then there's two size parameters one
is a bond dimension parameter and the
other is a size parameter
i will set and i'll call it usually s i
so what is this it's just a bunch
of tensors like this on eye sights
so a set of them like this so
it goes up to i
one each of these legs is d dimensional
this one is
um actually there's not going to be
i'm sorry here i'm just going to stop
like this
on the first high sides such that
the size of the set
is s
the bond dimension of these vectors
that most b
and
the important property is that the
haystack contains the needles right and
what does that mean so and
gamma tilde or some approximation to the
ground state so there exists some gamma
tilde
such that
it's a good approximation to the ground
state and
if i look at the reduced density
of gamma tilde on
the first i qubit so i'm tracing out i
plus 1 to n
of gamma theta
gamma tilde
this reduced density matrix is supported
on
the span so the linear span
of this set as high
right so it's worth parsing the
definition right so i just have a set of
vectors that live on the first i qubits
there's not too many vectors size s this
is going to stay polynomial and they all
have efficient representation matrix
products state of bond dimension at most
b and b is also a polynomial
such that the important property is that
there's something that's pretty close to
the ground state
one minus delta this is a delta
parameter and this thing that's close to
the ground state if i look at the left
half of it it's reduced density on the
first iq bit so we think of the schmidt
vectors
on the first iq dates then these are not
quite among my site but they're in the
linear span of the set
is there any relation between the
tensors corresponding to different
vectors in this set
um
no
it doesn't have and they could
definitely be linearly dependent
um if they are i could always prune it i
mean do some you know i i could assume
they're linearly independent but i'm not
going to worry about it um so there's no
there's not any general relation and the
relation between i s i and s one also at
this point
ah so i'll explain to you exactly so i'm
going to explain how to go from si to si
plus one so that's the that's the main
uh observations i mean there's two
simple important observations
the first observation is that
constructing this for i equals 1
is easy
so if i take s1
to be what i'll take s1 to be the set of
all
vectors
a basis let's say like this like this so
what i mean by this is i just mean a
basis for cd
cd then the claim is that i guess this
is just practicing with the definition
then s1 is
1
0 meaning very good uh bond dimension is
one or zero i don't know what you call
it and then the size there's going to be
d vector
is this clear um because you know
whatever my approximation to the ground
state is it has a reduced density on the
first qubit and that reduced density on
the first qubit is supported on the
space on which the first qubit lives
right so if i take a basis for that
space i'm sure that i'm that i'm good
is that okay or i see some puzzle looks
but it shouldn't be should be okay so
what is the last component
it's the local dimension of the qubit so
i just took a basis for cd and this is
oh it's the size of the set the number
of vectors
so it's not the bond
no the one dimension is the one before
i i put a one so right so i don't know
if you can see from where you are but b
is the bond dimension
and
so i i mean one dimension is zero right
i guess you you could call it zero
but
i thought that the qubit was defined by
your
system so you don't have control over
over there
sorry i mean the the the qubit right yes
you did yeah
but that's fixed right yes
it's given by the problem yeah
so why do you release it among the
parameters oh you mean that the size is
number is always going to be the size of
the set for that particular set the size
happens to be okay which is
advising just
it's a basis for cd my site is the basis
for
the first cuban the first qubit has
um d dimensions so it's e1 e2 e3
canonical basis so d to the i
achieve
equals
you want exactly right right i could
generalize this as a good point i could
i could generalize this uh to say that i
could i could get a set of size d to the
i and all these parameters being very
good of course d to the i when i is n is
exponential then
so it's actually the second observation
is that
given
sn which is
you know suppose i was given sn
which is let's say so n
and then let's say one over n cubed
and then i have poly bond dimension
and poly size
and variable
we are done
if i have this right because then in
that case what does it mean for set to
be viable when i have the whole chain
well it just means the reduced density
on all cubes i mean that's just gamma
tilde so i have a good approximation to
the ground state which is supported on
the span of my set
in that case i'll just be able to find
it by
minimizing the energy
over the span of my set which i i don't
want to write this to precisely but you
can write this as a convex programming
you can solve this efficiently in time
polynomial in the size of your
representations and the size of the set
you'll find the vector in that span that
minimizes the energy
and given this delta i'll get a good
approximation approximation
yeah delta divided by gap so
there was a question
does the algorithm requires you know
what that was the health time
sorry
do you need to know what delta is ahead
of time is in order to do this
by delta you mean yeah oh yeah
but just because it's it's uh
um
if i have a
lower bound on the gap this is fine um
it's just you saw how it scales with the
size of the gap as the gap gets smaller
the algorithm takes much more time so
when i set my parameters in the
algorithm i need to say the gap is at
least that much so that i need to only
consider you know things of that size
and we'll see that later
so if you have a lower bound on the gap
so you can always try i mean try a lower
bounce if it works or not
so it's it's not so clear to me that you
can optimize the convex programming
because it's a complicated object right
inside this tens or like this matrix
product same so it's not just a single
matrix yeah so what i look is that i i
look for a density matrix that's
supported on
the space
and the fact that it's supported on the
space means that i can write it as a
linear combination
of all these matrix product states which
so
what i'll do is i'll actually you know
the variables of the convex program will
be the energies of these individual
major scholar states not the matrix
value
but here i'd like to ask you to just uh
believe me that you can do it it's not
completely triggered but it's it's if
you write it properly you can do it
no um i could write anything so given a
set which is like this let's try the
delta
then my procedure what i'm describing
what you can do is we are done what i
mean by we are done is we can find
gamma tilde
such that the overlap so it depends what
you're interested in really but such
that the overlap of the ground state
will be at least
whatever this was by your gum
so you know if you're interested in a
constant approximation yeah you can you
can set that to a positive the reason
i'm setting it to be um one over n cubed
here is that as we go through the stages
of the algorithm it's going to be
important at various points to have
deltas which are inverse polynomial in
size even if at the end you're only
interested in the constant approximation
this is this uh sort of fridge procedure
that
will make that smaller
this is just a so far it's a definition
right and the definition says that you
know if a set
is viable then
there is a good approximation to the
ground state which lies in that set
oh so i'm using the gap i'm sorry yes so
um
if i minimize the energy over my set
because of the gap the vector that i
find is necessarily going to be a good
approximation to the ground state
given that there was one in there of
course right so my promise is saying
that i can find
a state that has low enough energy
uniqueness
i didn't mention it but but i guess
you're right you're right so
i am using uniqueness and
i'm sorry
it's possible that you have exact space
no no so my assumption is that there's a
unique ground state
and there's a gap above that
did not get yeah you don't get the
real prostate
but instead you get a
uh
step that's a lot
lower minimum of what so
you get an
excited no no i'm not going to get it i
know i don't that's it okay so i don't
know
maybe
no no no i'm waiting to hear about some
americans could find an eigen state
separately yeah i mean that's a
guarantee of our algorithm it's right
it's going it's
um
what i did want to say here is that sort
of this haystack procedure it's easy to
get started
and if we manage to make it till the end
while keeping all the parameters under
control then we're in good shape and
then this is what i have to explain to
you how we
build these sets from left uh to right
and maybe
well okay i can write it here so there's
only four steps uh two of them are
interesting to our trivial so i'll say
what the four steps are and then i'll
focus on the on the two interesting ones
so here's the iterative step
so what we'll start with
i'll just assume that i have a set which
is has these quantities so 2
b 0
s 0
these b 0 s 0 um
they're fixed polynomials in n i mean if
you want to
just think of them as being n cubed or
into the 4 we'll see as we go
what they are right but i assume that i
have such a thing and i'm going to make
it better
in four steps
so the first step
is the fridge is is in saying look here
you have a set i mean all things are
good except the quality of the
approximation half this is kind of a
little bit a little bit tight i want to
make this better so we have a procedure
that's going to transform such a thing
into
something that still lives on the same
space but now is
has much better approximation
s
at the cost of increasing these
parameters
so that's the procedure that i call the
fridge or it's called also agsp
the idea is going to be to use the
hamiltonian use the local hamiltonian
from it
construct a local operator an mpo
that you're going to apply to all the
vectors in your set
and you're going to have to guarantee
that
if these vectors contained a half
approximation as you apply this mpo
they'll contain better and better
approximations
but the applying the mpo will have a
cost it'll blow up the bond dimension
it'll blow up the size by polynomial
factors
so the other steps are going to improve
uh that actually
not quite yet the next step is sort of a
trivial step which is going to increase
uh add one more qubit i'll now consider
vectors over i have to make progress
towards the right right i'll keep the
same approximation quality i'll keep the
same bond dimension
and the only thing is that the size will
again increase a little bit
think of this as just doing the same
kind of trivial thing as we did here i
just take all my matrix product states
and i add a basis for the next qubit to
all of them so i multiply my size by d
this is really easy to do it's trivial i
just couldn't afford to do it at every
step because i can't multiply the size
of my set at every step by d i'll get
something exponentially large so the
next two steps are trying to get us back
to things under control
so the first one is another interesting
step so it's the
fire step or the
decoupling step
this is going to use um
the 1d structure and the gap
and the array law to drastically reduce
the size of this set
at the cost of messing up unfortunately
the nice approximation we had so it'll
bring it back up to some large constant
these bond dimensions will go up even
some more
but the size will go down to the
original size
so that's what this step is doing right
i had a big set contained a very good
approximation
but i have a way to set things on fire
reduce the size by a lot to something of
constant size this this will really use
the fact that um
as we're making prog well i'll
i'll
say more about it later and then the
last step is again an easy step is just
reducing the bond dimension
so i'm just going to trim these vectors
in a very naive way just cut off the
large schmidt coefficients i'll lose a
little bit in the error
but i'll be able to bring things back to
the same
states as they were before
that's tempting
so if we're able to carry out these four
steps we can go from here to here
and we're done right
and what i'm claiming is that this step
is trivial i think maybe most of you can
see it i'm also claiming that this is
pretty trivial just cut the bond
dimension or
you use the fact that
well you have to say why you can afford
to do that with the i'm not going to go
into it it's
exercise so the two interesting set
steps are a and c
and i like i think a is the most
interesting uh step here because it's
the part where you're not doing
exhaustive search you're doing something
smart um
this is exhaustive search just adding a
qubit anything to it
this is guided search it's saying you
have a reasonable approximation you're
making up a much better approximation
so let me say something about this and
if i have time i'll also say something
about this
when you said that the hamiltonian was
local does that mean nearest neighbor
yeah
so i guess you could
i mean if it's
you know if it's
two or three i mean if it has finite
interaction length then i can always
block stuff
um but but but i don't know how to you
know if it's something that's decaying
then i don't know what happens there
what is b z where there's zero like they
never they're fixed constants they're
universal polynomials no polynomials
in l you know so i could write the
formula they look a little bit like the
parameters of the algorithm so b zero is
something think of it as being n to the
two
to the one over delta
and s zero is something they're just set
to that
so already in the second step
you are increasing these two and then
well no i mean no no because in the
second step my things live on the space
of dimension
yes
i mean naively yeah because anyways it's
going to increase later i mean it's not
like i'll save much by improving the
second
step yeah
i think i'll have time to say something
about a but not maybe not
about c opportunity but let's let's see
a unless there's other questions
all right
so how do you improve
in particular this step
relies on the gap
and the local structure
but not one dimensions
so it's something that you can extend uh
to two dimensions or more so maybe it's
a instinct object so suppose you had the
following this is sort of your your
dream object suppose
there exists some operator k
it's an operator that acts on the whole
chain
it's positive and it has three
properties
the first property is that when you
apply k
to the ground
state you keep the ground state
this is the thing that we call
approximate ground state projection so
it leaves the ground state invariant
then it has the property that if you
take any
side
that is orthogonal to the ground state
so any excited state in particular
such that side gamma equals zero then
the norm
k applied to psi
this is at most inverse polynomial let's
say 1 over n cubed times the norm upside
squared so it keeps the ground state in
parent it shrinks the other states
so it's probably one property two
property three is that
k has a matrix product operation
matrix product operator representation
with small bond dimension let's say you
know i'll just write poly and bond
dimension
one dimension
so i'm going to claim that if i have
such an operator i can accomplish step a
and then i'm going to tell you how to
get such an operator from the local
hamiltonian
so it's useful to notice that if i apply
then
if i apply k
to even something that's an
approximation
to the ground state
then this operator okay i should write
it like this then this operator
and then i look at what's the the state
i look at the overlap with the ground
state then this is going to be bigger
than let's
um i don't know what the numbers are
exactly but let's say
4 probably this is okay 4 over n cubed
right if gamma tilde
gamma
is greater than half so if i start with
a vector on the whole on the whole chain
right that's a good approximation to the
ground state
i apply k to it the component of that
vector that is on the ground state is
left invariant and the component that
orthogonal to the vector gets shrunk by
a huge factor one over n cubed
yeah they're normalized i'm sorry so i
should divide
this by the norm
thank you
this is always normalized but this one i
should have been
given the norm right
okay
so that just follows from the first two
properties and now the claim is that so
okay um
the claim is that if i define i'm going
to tell you what the the new set is now
this
sia let's call it si prime
let's write it like this i'm going to
write it as applying the operator
i'll tell you what this index is
afterwards and then i had
to the vectors that were in my set
right for every vector so these are the
vectors that are in the original set as
i
and to each of them i apply these
operators so what are these operators
well
what i want to do is really apply on the
whole operator k but k is an operator
that acts on the whole chain the way i
defined it so if i start with something
like this and i want to apply my mpo
well it's fine except the mpo sort of
continues right and it's kind of asking
me well what would you what do you plug
in here
so the way to apply uh such an mpo to a
vector that stops here is simply to cut
the mpo
look at the different values that this
bond can take and that's my index j
and so this here
is kj which is something that only acts
on the left half of my chain i have as
many kj's as uh the original operator
had the
uh the original
as the bond dimension of the original
mpo and i'm going to apply every single
one of them to my vectors
and so
maybe you can see that if the original
set
if gamma tilde was supported the left
half of gamma tilde was supported on
these vectors
then the left half of k applied to gamma
tilde is supported on the span of all
these vectors so all the vectors that
they are plane obtained by taking any
vector in s i and applying any of these
kj operators
to it
so this set has the required properties
the approximation quality has improved
to this number i mean i could just uh
make it better if i wanted
what happened to the size the size got
multiplied by this bond that i had to
cut
which is a fixed polynomial i mean
that's the promise that i'm giving you
and the bond dimension has also been
multiplied by whatever the bond
dimension of my mpo was
so these parameters the parameters b
prime and s prime that i get here
they're both b0 and s0 times
whatever the bond dimension of this mpo
is and as long as this is reasonable i
haven't blown up by too much
the next thing is i just want to give
you a idea of
where this mpo comes from um
is that okay
so there is something
about that that slightly that that chain
does not continue to the end whereas the
button does continue to the ends right
is it like a problem or no i think it's
no no it's not a problem it's just a
minor
technicality it's just the way
i'm going to show you how to construct
this operator k it's natural to think of
it as acting on the whole chain
now you want to make it act only on the
half so you're just cutting in the
middle
and taking all possible values for
whatever could be coming from the right
hand side which is why i'm sticking in
any possible index j here to the right
hand side and considering all cases so
that in a way i'm saying whatever the
right hand side was
um
yeah
i couldn't i i keep my approximation
so how do you find k yeah so i'm going
to define i guess this is probably the
last thing i do but first five minutes
is enough so it's it's a it's a simple
uh construction but maybe it's maybe
it's useful it's constructed directly
from the local hamiltonian
so you know if this was not completely
clear maybe just let's see how we can
construct a operator that has these uh
these properties
so
let's look first at this so let's take
uh parameter m and let's look at this
operator now so i'll look at am
which takes the hamiltonian
it scales it by n
it looks like identity minus
so this is
between zero and one right because
there's n terms and each of the terms
has normal at most one so this is
positive
i'm going to scale it so there's a
little bit of a scaling scale it by
one minus the smallest energy
by n
this is the scaling and then i raise
this to the power m
so the first thing this is just a
definition right um
another way to i mean this is
well okay let me not see
that
first i want to show you that this
operator satisfies
the first two properties
but then it doesn't look like a
reasonable npo and we'll have to do
something to fix that
but let's first study the first two
properties so let's look at what's the
effect of am on the ground state
well first the ground state is going to
be an eigenvector of this just because
this is identity it's an eigenvector of
h and that's the only things that i'm
doing so the only thing i have to do is
compute the eigenvalue
and once the eigenvalue is going to be
something raised to the m then i'll have
1 minus e0 over n because it's the
ground state times 1 over 1 minus e 0
over n
almost time for the y reception
gamma so this is good right and now if i
take
psi which is orthogonal to gamma
let's say to simplify let me take uh
psi
such that it's
one of the excited states right so such
that psi h psi an eigenvector of h with
energy
e1
so in that case
am psi because i'm assuming it's an
eigenvector just just for simplicity
i'll get psi then what do i get inside
my brackets here i still have the
normalization 1 minus e0 over n except
that this term now is 1 minus e1 over n
e1 is at least e0 plus delta so i'll get
something like this
and then you can see that this is
how this behaves is basically like i'm
not going to do the calculation but it's
basically something that behaves 1 minus
delta over n
to the m
yes thank you
so you need to
know the value of e0
no i need to know the value of delta to
set the end parameter i need m to be at
least
yeah you're right but it's uh
um in a way this is just a global
scaling right i could just pull it out
it's just a constant that's outside so
if i say if i think of keeping vectors
that i normal that are normalized have
no one then this this actually doesn't
really matter it's it's a multiplier so
you know if i choose the wrong one
there'll be a multiplier here and the
same multiplier here and up to
normalization
it won't really matter
well
i mean
right yeah
yeah this is roughly what this is doing
the same way except
this one i know how to think about in
terms of making it uh into a mpo that
has more by one dimension i think if you
want to think of this as e to the minus
beta h for some good choice of beta and
then
what i'm going to do right now think of
it as being cauterization then it would
be the same
it's this is i find this easier to state
but
if you're used to
other things yeah
so but i should really um
tell you how to think of this as an mpo
and then and then we'll be
there's just one uh
when i say the other so what is this i
can expand it right and i can write am
as so there's this constant in front 1
minus 1 minus e 0 over n
to the m and then i can expand
this summation
and i can write it as the sum over terms
and what do the terms look like
this here i want to write as 1 over n
times
1 minus h1
plus 1 minus h2
plus 1 minus h
n minus 1
let's go to h m because i put n i don't
want it it should be n minus 1 but it's
ok
so if i expand this summation i get
products of terms which look like 1
minus
could be anything right 1 minus h i 1
1 minus h i 2
i have m of them 1 minus h i
m
and these indices i 1 up to i m
they range in 1
to n so so i just expanded so this is
what my operator looks like so far it's
a sum of many many terms and what do
these terms look like
well what does this let me call this p
i one they look like terms like this p
i one and then maybe the second one pi2
is maybe something like this
pi2
and maybe pi3 is here
maybe i have pi4 is is here
and this is the operator that i'm trying
to apply
to my vectors it just has these all
these uh
p which are one minus h they come from
the hamiltonian they're local terms and
they're arranged in an arbitrary order
so if i think of this as an mpo this
maybe has very large uh bond dimension
because some of the terms in that sum
involve for instance you know pi1 pi2
then pi1 could be the same again and i
could have a long chain like this of m
and my m is n so i could have one of the
terms in here is a long chain that has
all these projections that keep acting
on the first two qubits over and over
again and times so the one dimension of
this would be something like d to the n
it's exponential so far the dimension
didn't if i represent this naively as an
empire it has exponential bond dimension
but the observation is that
this is not typical
oh yeah i forgot that sorry thanks yeah
another normalization yeah
um
the observation is that there's many
many terms in here and some of them are
bad like this one two one two one two
term has a huge bond dimension
there's many terms and as left just
pointed out these terms are scaled by a
very small factor so as long as there is
few terms
that have huge bond dimension
i can remove them and approximate this
operator by only terms that are better
behaved that look like something like
this one which
such that across any bond i only have
a constant or at most logarithmic if i
want to keep a point number one
dimension logarithmic number of
projections that act across any one bond
here
and this is what we're going to do we're
going to say
think of this as
a superposition over exponentially many
terms
and use these
something called a matrix turn off bound
to sample we're going to say this
operator is well approximated
by
taking a polynomial size
number of these terms uniformly at
random among all possibilities and
renormalizing
so the claim
and really over time
won't state it precisely
is that for our purposes
am
is well approximated
by
the appropriate scaling
times
the sum of these things
1 minus h i 1
etc up to 1 minus h i n
the sum over what now not all possible
indices but just a random
polysized subset
of indices
and this approximation is an
approximation an operator norm up to an
error that i can make inverse polynomial
uh if i want so that's what's known as a
matrix external bound or concentration
bound for
sums of random matrices
so that's going to be the mpo this is
going to be k
the last thing to check is that if i
check if i take only polynomially many
of these possibilities
the chance that i get any one
which acts too many times across any
given bond is sufficiently small that i
can basically consider it's not going to
happen i mean if it happens uh let's say
i sample again
so you
get a randomized uh algorithm
so yeah you said this uh follows from a
random matrix theory result yeah
but well it depends on your code
so i thought you said it only
i thought i heard you say that
approximate equality is because of a
random matrix result yeah matrix general
form
so but you don't assume that your local
terms are necessary no no no not at all
i think of uh i think of of this this
product here
as a random variable my sample space is
all possible values for the product and
the random variable takes you know this
value with probability
this number and that's that's that's
very of course the hamiltonian is not
random
any
okay so i should wrap up i
told you what
ingredient number one was then i'm sorry
i don't have time
to say so this was the procedure that
lets you the fridge that lets you
improve the quality of your set the
procedure that's missing is the fire
that reduces the size of the set this is
an idea that was already present in
earlier exponential time algorithms
for the same problem it's called this
decoupling it uses the fact
that
this is a one-dimensional chain to say
that once you've progressed up to here
and you have all these set of candidate
solutions what's important about them
it's not how they look up to here what's
important is just that they can be
extended you're going to be able to make
progress they can be extended into a
state that has a low enough energy
and whether something that lives on here
can be extended
to something that has a low energy
only depends on how it looks like at the
boundary
and let's say it's total energy to the
left right but it doesn't depend on how
these tensors look like here so there's
a pruning step this is the step i didn't
explain this decoupling step does some
pruning to say among my huge haystack i
only need to keep one possible candidate
for
every way you know every possibility for
how this
the contraction up to here looks like in
big terms and this lets me cut down a
lot because there's much fewer
contractions than the size of my set
there's a fixed number throughout the
algorithm which is the dimension of my
space the bond and the local dimension
polynomial
i'm skipping a lot of details but i'm
really over time so i should stop if
there's any questions well there's a
reception coming up yeah
your algorithm give one dimension d by
the time you get to the end
uh d or b or
d